okay so I've mentioned steam it before
st double e MIT the david pakman show
started publishing content there and a
curating content on steam it steam it is
a blockchain based platform where
earnings are attributed to content not
by virtue of ads that play like on
YouTube but by virtue of how much the
audience on steam it enjoys the content
by uploading it and one thing that I did
is about a week ago I published a post
on Steam it and we're on steam it by the
way steam it calm slash at David Pakman
link is in the video description I said
hey I'm gonna answer some questions on
our YouTube channel from steam it users
the idea being to engage with the steam
it community and also tell the YouTube
community about steam it so hopefully
part of our YouTube following will go to
steam it and follow us an upvote our
content there many of you ask questions
I don't have time to answer all of them
but I am going to answer some and let's
start with the first one if we may
from cryptic skeptic who said what are
your thoughts on universal basic income
the pace of AI and robotics advances
recently led me lead me to believe we
may need it or similar solutions in as
soon as 10 to 20 years in order to avoid
a complete economic meltdown if that's
true then it needs to be considered more
in current political discussion so the
idea isn't completely foreign to the
public when we need it
yeah I've been an advocate of a
universal basic income for a long time I
have both expressed some concerns with
it in terms of how it might be
implemented and also talked about how it
should be implemented and one of the key
things and have a number of videos on
this so I won't go into extreme detail
here you can search our YouTube channel
but one of the issues with universal
basic income is that it needs to be
completely not means-tested meaning that
no matter whether you are or aren't
working whether you do or don't have
other income sources the whole point of
it is to be really cheap to administer
you just get the money right and you can
do whatever you want for it with it that
has to be part of it I have expressed
concern that some of the big tech
billionaires have been more and more
getting behind universal basic income
and I'm not concerned because I think
that they're bad people but I think it's
important
for us to be aware of the fact that we
would not want a situation where by
virtue of having a universal basic
income it becomes more acceptable to
forget about the realities of huge
income inequality and other economic
problems that we have by saying hey look
we did universal basic income to all of
our problems are solved it's not going
to be a panacea but I do support it's a
really good question and check out some
of the other material about it
next question from steam it no no no
what's that
yo David yo yo no I'm saying the user
name is knower angel I don't know how it
would be pronounced no arrange 'l anyway
he looks like a guy from the picture
says yo david what do you make of Tom
DeLonge or Tommy the longe claiming
aliens are real and then backs it up
with guys from the CIA and Pentagon he a
cougar does he know something we don't
I looked into this a little bit I don't
really know anything about this
particular guy and it's not the same
guys like the blink 182 Todd didn't Tom
DeLonge have a member name I didn't know
nothing about this I'm realizing yeah
anyway there was a guy in blink 182
named Tom DeLonge and I don't know if
it's the same spelling is this is a
different guy from what I understand I
don't know about his claims I mean
i-i've said before I think that
mathematically it's very likely that we
are not alone in the universe and if you
familiarize yourself with some of the
mathematics around why that could be
true and yet we may never we have never
heard from other intelligent alien
species species you can sort of
understand that part of it I do believe
that we are not alone in the universe
but do I think Tom DeLonge has the
knowledge about the alien contact that
he claims has been made or whatever no I
don't think so I mean generally we there
have been so many of these claims over
time Pat and they've really all been
none have been substantiated and some
have been debunked and I don't think
that there are people on earth right now
who have made contact with aliens and
I've said this before and I'll say it
again
why are a lien so obsessed with anal
probing right that I've brought that up
before why do so many alien abduction
stories involve anal probe and why are
they so secretive - they can tell one or
two people on the planet but they can't
make it known to all seven billion of us
right they've picked and and why is it
that the people
let me put it a different way if you
take a survey of the people that claim
to have had contact with aliens any
normal person would say why are the
aliens picking these people to reveal
their their existence - okay next
question from steam it comped was 64 do
you have any plans to utilize the steam
video player D tube I don't have an
answer for you yet I'm aware of D tube
currently we've been uploading our
content to YouTube as normal and then
embedding that into the steam it
platform and I know that we can use D
tube I think if we did like exclusive
for steam at content that would be the
type of thing to put on D tube but for
now it's not something that we've done
but I am aware of it and we're also
looking at utopian dot IO
as a possible place for putting some of
our content up next question from steam
it by the way how many do we have Pat
I've five total ok this is number three
for more thrust says is the sound in
your walls back now that it's getting
cold again so the back story on this is
that last winter I started noticing that
so my apartment has one of those
electronic digital schedulable
thermostats hmm and I don't like it hot
while I'm sleeping so I would allow the
temperature to fall to 66 during the
night and if I get up at 7:30 I would
set the thing to turn back on at about
7:15 or 7 and the problem was because of
the change in temperature during the
winter it would start sort of my entire
apartment would start creaking there
would be noises in the walls and it
would make wake me up way before I
wanted to be up yeah I mean I always
thought that you you're only supposed to
change a thermostat like two degrees at
a time yeah well believe me I'm breaking
that rule every single day so what I did
last winter was I scheduled in my
thermostat instead of just going from 66
to 70 right at 7 a.m. at 4:30 a.m. it
would go to 67 degrees and at 5:30 a.m.
it would go to 68 degrees and at 6:30
a.m. the idea to more slowly bring the
place up to temperature it's like an
alarm that gets louder and louder in a
sense it's time to get up in a sense
and it actually did work last winter and
I'm doing the exact same thing this
winter and for some reason the creaking
is completely back and I don't know if
it's that the apartment needs to become
react LeMay 'td to these changes in
temperature even though they're smaller
now but the noise in my walls is
completely back it's like a cracking
noise that starts sometimes at 6:00 a.m.
6:30 a.m. it's not good it's not good so
yes thank you for your concern and the
noise is back and lastly from our steam
it thread another question from
schrock's tough one to say I disagree
with your disdain for seer 0% interest
deals mostly because I have one running
right now I'm paying the minimum payment
to the store and saving the remainder
and an investment account until a month
or two before the deferred interest
kicks in I've only earned $13 on what
I've set aside so far which is actually
four point seven percent but it's a tiny
principal but that's better than zero
the only caveat you made that I may
concede is that people may spend more if
they're offered zero percent but that
seems subjective at a professor that
told us be fast to take money in and
slow to paid money out to take to pay
money out all else being equal which I
think 0% equalizes things a bit I would
certainly never refer to the price of an
item as X dollars per month though
that's barbaric
listen I don't think this person
disagrees with me I said it's true that
when you get a no interest deal at a
store if you don't spend money that you
wouldn't have otherwise spent because of
the zero interest and if you are on the
ball enough that you are going to pay it
off before that year of no interest is
up because otherwise you get all the
back interest added to your account then
yes it can be advantageous but overall
many people nobody thinks they're
influenced by pricing psychology but it
exists for a reason which is that people
are influenced by it and these stores
know that if you're offered 0% interest
you might not think twice about spending
another couple hundred bucks on a TV for
example because hey after all you're
paying for it over 12 months so I don't
know that we disagree that drastically I
think that we're basically on the ball
and you sound like one of the people
that can actually take advantage of the
zero interest deal and in your case make
a four point seven return as a result of
that all right thanks to everybody who
asked questions we will do this again
follow us on steam it up vote our
content link in
video-description steam it double e
steam it comm / @ sign David Pakman